the robot learning and reasoning lab
um uh where he advances robotics by
combining machine learning, uh computer
vision, and planning in order to build
adaptable general-purpose robots.
Uh he is also a researcher at Nvidia AI
and earned his PhD in computer science
from Stanford University uh with uh
Fei-Fei Li and Silvio Savarese.
And uh Dan Fei's work has earned
significant recognition including
uh a National Science Foundation Career
Award and uh his research portfolio
includes award-winning publications and
innovations in imitation learning,
long-horizon task reasoning, and uh
robot learning systems.
And with that uh we're very excited to
hear uh about your work, Dan Fei. Take
it away.
All right. Thanks for your kind
introduction.
Hi everyone.
Uh cool. All right. So um I know I think
the lecture today is about imitation
learning, right? I I was looking through
the syllabus. Is that right?
Oh, yeah. What's that?
>> Could you confirm?
Uh is the uh lecture to Was the lecture
today about imitation learning?
>> learning. Yes. Awesome. All right. So,
that's a fitting topic. So
Okay. So, but it's more a kind of
contra- uh
I want to say contrarian view, but more
a kind of alternative view for imitation
learning. So, hopefully um uh that
connects to what you you've seen today.
Um so, uh specifically the talk I'm
going to give today is really examining
a very simple hypothesis that we can
scale robot capability uh with human
experience data. And uh most robot
learning today uh kind of still depends
mostly on teleoperated demonstration
data. And in contrast, uh LLMs and VLMs
are successful because they can learn
from naturally occurring human data
crawled from the internet. So, the
question is, can we scale robot
uh can robot learning scale the same way
from natural human behaviors?
So, to think about this, let me start
with a more conceptual view of robot
learning. So, my view is that modern
robot learning has three core couple
components,
data source, the learning algorithms and
models, and the physical system.
You cannot change one in
in isolation. Progress really comes from
co-designing all three of them all
together. So, I call this the triangle
of robot learning. And from this
perspective, we can now kind of track a
recent trend shift in the field, which
is a growing focus on changing the data
source, rather than only improving the
models.
The most dominant trend today is perhaps
learning from teleoperated
demonstrations. And
we we can
at the same time examining their their
algorithms and hardware systems.
So, just by manually, so for those of
you who are not kind of have not done
this kind of research before, just kind
of giving some examples
where just by manually control the robot
with some devices like VR controllers,
you can collect expert demonstration to
train robot policies and to end from
pixel fractions. And we've seen this
both success in academia and industry, a
lot of really impressive demos for
solving tasks we thought were previously
not possible,
like such as doing laundry and making
pizzas.
So, we should have already covered this
kind of topic today, but I'll give you a
just more practical sense of how we
actually tell our
collective teleperson data and train
policy model. I'm just giving example
with an work I did with J and I did back
in 2020.
So, when human operate a robot using
control device such as like a smartphone
here, we capture two streams of data,
what a robot senses and how it should
act. This gives you the really the
ground truth control signals for a robot
given observation input. And importantly
is that here is that we're not just
kind of transferring the actual
knowledge by perceiving and acting
through the robot's body, we're training
a model, a policy model,
uh, as sort of
by kind of transferring this kind of
embodied sensorimotor knowledge that is
not really existing, uh, in the today's
internet data. So, that that's really
kind of not really natural or the
occurring human knowledge, but more more
of a kind of deliberate demonstrative
data.
And when we when we revisit the
triangle, collaboration creates really a
tight coupling among all these three
components. Data is generated only when
humans act through a specific robot, and
algorithm then learn from that robot
specific data, and the resulting
policies only work on this the same
hardware configuration that you collect
data on. And this this really prevents
the system from scale, uh, to to collect
more data, you need more robots, and to
change the embodiments, you really need
to recollect the data on that target
robot.
So, this leads to a really tight
bottleneck, uh, or a very tight
knowledge transfer bottleneck. Humans
have enormous sensorimotor knowledge
about physical world, but we only
capture the knowledge when the day we
deliberately act through robots, and
this knowledge is really like,
uh, kind of waste of human knowledge,
right? We're we're we're kind of
throwing away most of our natural, uh,
knowledge about how we interact with
this world. So, the question is, can we
transfer the sensorimotor knowledge from
humans to robots at scale similar to how
it's happening in vision and natural
language processing?
And our proposal is to break this
bottleneck by removing the data from the
data collection
data collection loop. So, instead of
recording humans acting through robots,
uh, we learn from humans acting acting
naturally in the world. This kind of
data contains rich sensory experience,
can be collected with at much larger
scale with our robots, and it really
doesn't really uh require any
intentional demonstrations. So,
uh and so, the question then becomes
whether we can turn this human
experience into useful supervisions for
robot policies.
So, as I mentioned before, we cannot
change one thing uh with this robot
experience as a data source. We have to
rethink how to capture and learn from
the data, as well as the rest of the
robot hardware systems.
And this brings us to our first research
milestone, uh which uh not sure uh have
you have seen some of you have seen it.
It's called Ego Mimics, Scaling
Imitation Learning via Egocentric Video.
Uh the core of this project is to
capture embodied human data with an
egocentric view with wearable devices,
uh which means that we can collect this
data anywhere.
Uh unlike third-person views, egocentric
data really capture how we humans
perceive the world at an eye level.
And specifically, we use the Project
Aura glasses, which is kind of a pair of
uh smart glasses, uh to capture this
data. Uh
it kind of gives you the essential
sensory experiences I'm going to talk
about a little later.
And our work really is about turning
these raw data stream into embodied
human data that can be treated uh as
equals with robot data. So, uh we So, we
no longer treat kind of human data as
human data, but more of human as kind of
different different kind of robot. We
have input and output. We just find to
capture it and put it alongside the
robot data to to train them up. And in
order to do this, we have to bridge
sensing, action, and kinematic gaps, and
develop really this joint policy
learning architecture that scales
primarily with human data.
Um so, let's first uh talk about how to
align embodiments and viewpoints between
human robots. Uh so, for embodiments,
it's not really like a challenge uh as
of 2026, but back then when we started
this project in 2023, there weren't many
kind of robots human-like robots that
kind of mimics the
embodiments of humans. So, we actually
had to kind of think about how to design
a lightweight and lean robots that are
human-like. So, we kind of built our own
robots with two six-arm and some of
these devices. But one interesting thing
is that we actually mimic the viewpoint
of humans and I would actually even use
the exact same sensing device as humans,
which is this pair of eye glasses. So,
we mount our glasses on the robot so
they have a very similar camera hardware
specification and viewpoint so that they
can kind of minimize the inter-device
inter-embodiment gaps.
Among the many problems we had to solve
to learn from the egocentric data, I
want to kind of highlight one of very
interesting one, which is the viewpoint
shifts. When we work with robot like
ours, the robot's viewpoint moves
relative to like a fixed reference
frame. Right? You can easily get action
trajectories in the fixed kind of
reference space frame.
But with egocentric human data, like the
ones I just showed you on the left, the
chef cooking preparing dinner,
we kind of our head naturally moves, we
look around, check workspaces, focus on
different tasks. This means that a hand
position tracked relative to a moving
reference frame. We need to really
stabilize this reference frame to make
human hand motion
like usable as robot robot supervision
action supervision for robot learning.
And luckily, we were able to do this
because Arya already gave us like a
really really good
slam system that can sort of track the
head motion relative to hand or our hand
relative to the head more of
so it would actually turn us into a
stable reference frame. So,
in the first row, we have these kind of
moving reference frame where head is
everywhere, head is everywhere, but now
we can actually transform this uh fixed
world coordinate frame from SLAM map to
transform all the trajectories to a
fixed base frame. To This allows us to
create these kind of very stable
trajectory uh relative to a camera
frame.
Um so, with all of this kind of input
output aligned, uh we actually were able
to design a very simple uh kind of deep
behavior cloning system. Uh you probably
have already seen this in the previous
lecture. So, it's really a supervised
learning problem where you have input uh
observations, let's say sensing and
pre-perception, and output actions. And
we basically put human pose human robot
uh data together, did some normalization
that, if you're interested in, you
should read the paper. Uh but uh this is
really kind of how we put together the
system. And our hypothesis is that if
you just train this policy with more
human data, the robot performance would
increase with just that same amount of
robot data. So, uh the hypothesis is
that we want to drive the robot
performance uh primarily with human
data.
And we test this uh this kind of policy
on a variety of different tasks, like a
bagging grocery tasks, uh where like
kind of uh you have to lift up bag
handle and put all of these kind of
groceries in in a bag. Uh and you can
see that it kind of
is a closed-loop policy that kind of
corrects the the mistakes.
And folding clothes.
And uh also making pour-over coffees uh
for for our graduate students.
I'll just let this this uh video finish
playing.
Um
Um yeah.
It's a very hard task. Succeeds once in
a while.
Um the but the true question is that
does Ego motion scale with human data?
And to check this, we actually did this
kind of tiny scaling law uh experiments,
where x-axis is hour data you collect
either on human robots and y-axis is a
score of performance. And you can see
that with only a robot data, this blue
line, you can see this kind of mild
scaling curve. With more teleop data, a
teleop robot data, the performance
goes gets better. But if at at sort of
once you have a certain amount of robot
data, if you just add this human data
into the training mix, you can
dramatically see this dramatic jump in a
robot performance. And this basically
validates our hypothesis that human data
is a viable way to drive up the robot
performance. And one of the reasons is
that we humans actually collect kind of
demonstrate a lot faster than
teleoperation. So some for some some
tasks up to 10 times faster than
teleoperation. And remember that also
the nice thing is that we don't need a
robot in the loop, so you can just
provide us demonstration anywhere.
Um so we also moved this robot to kind
of variety part of campus to show the
robustness of this.
This these videos are on on the website,
so if you're interested you can watch
them.
Uh
so in interest of time I'm going to kind
of skip and talk about sort of like what
what kind of try robot learning
framework has built, which is that we
now have this human data source as the
environment as the data source human
experience as data source and we had to
change our physical robot environment
and also algorithms.
But I can I can imagine that just
co-training human robot data is not the
most sophisticated algorithm out there.
It's essentially still just behavior
cloning. So the question is can we do
better?
And before that we have to check what's
missing, right? So what we've seen in
Google makes that it scales. So it
scales with the robot robot policy
performance with human data.
What is missing really is that those
tasks that human demonstrator has to
exist in a robot data. So, in so to say,
we have to pair collect this kind of
paired and distributed virtual data from
human robots in order for a robot to
kind of improve its performance.
Um and the dream of our our our kind of
vision really is that we want to have
this kind of zero-shot transfer, which
is that we want a robot to be able to do
something that only exists in human
data. So, uh and clearly this
co-training objective like other
algorithms uh still cannot achieve that.
So, what's missing?
Um so, what what So, what is actually
what we are hypothesizing, which is like
ideal picture of like what how how
should robot can do the zero-shot
transfer, is to learn this kind of
generalizable domain invariant latent
space such that, let's say, you have
human data of folding shirts and robot
data of folding shirts, which are blue
and orange dots, and you map them into
this latent space, and your policy model
basically decodes this into an action.
And when a new batch of data arrives,
folding shirts and folding shorts, which
doesn't exist in robot data, uh but only
in human data,
uh your encoder in this domain invariant
latent space should ideally map this to
the same space so that the policy can
still generate reasonable actions for
this new task while you don't really
have any robot data for. So, that's our
ideal picture.
But what happens in practice, as
discovered by our student lead Ryan, is
that it's actually not learning this
invariant space. They are like pretty
separate. Human robot data are are kind
of they're very isolated. They're two
two really just two clusters.
So, the question uh Well, there are many
reasons other ways that we can kind of
uh
enable this zero-shot transfer, but our
specific hypothesis here really is that
maybe if we can pull this these
distribution together to form this late
latent space through some learning
algorithms, we could actually enable
stronger human robot transfer. And this
is where sort of our policy our work
near experiment paper we call Eagle
Bridge come in. Uh
without getting too much details, this
is really kind of a joint distribution
alignment algorithm between human
between human robot data. So we joint
align these state action or observation
action distribution between the two data
sources via optimal transport. Uh so in
case if you have not learned So optimal
transport is sort of this like
distribution matching algorithm and if
you
implement this
like in a specific way it's
differentiable so you can actually use
this as a way to kind of pull
distributions together without
destroying their respective marginal
distribution structure. So
uh
kind of just kind of skip over the
equations here, but the takeaway here is
that is a very general algorithm you can
use a variety of ways to decide on how
to pull these distributions together
and by designing this cost function. Uh
so the cost function we use is kind of
matching their action shapes. So human
robot should have roughly same similar
shape of like sort of six shape of
trajectories when they do similar
things. We use that as a supervision to
draw them together but you can use other
things like language description and so
other reliable weak supervision signals
to pull these distributions together.
And the algorithm itself is quite simple
so it's just a additional absolute loss
on top of our Eagle Bridge pipeline so
it's kind of plug and play. Um so there
instead of one loss you have two losses.
And as a result we do see that on the
left side Eagle Bridge in like largely
improved the alignment between human
robots because it's actually a bit hard
to see but you can see all of these
orange dots behind all all these orange
dots there actually blue dots behind
them. So they're kind of more or less
aligned and
yeah so there parts of the data that do
not align, but we observe that
empirically as the the model does
improve performance. And if you actually
visualize the nearest neighbor points
between human robot, they actually show
that they have very similar behaviors.
Like, if you visualize the the images a
bit.
So So So, we do see like
improvements in performance. And also,
we also see some early signs of solving
tasks that only seem in robot data. For
example,
human data. For example, we designed
this task where the robot has to
basically uh so you start from
beginning. So, human demonstrated on
this
this all of these regions where you kind
of open a drawer and put something in
it. The robot robot data only covers the
the the purple kind of quadrants of
these. So, there's a only one region
that that's does not cover by robot
data, but only by human data. So, we can
see that robot is actually
able to solve this task with a
significant boost in performance. So,
most of the methods will not be able to
do this in this kind of drawing.
So, so
so kind of just to kind of tie back to
triangle. So, we were able to kind of
improve the algorithm to to make sure
that the whole cycle kind of
are consistent with what we are trying
to achieve here, which is learning from
human data.
But now, what we'll be seeing doing is
kind of largely just focusing on table
top manipulation data tasks.
So, what if we want to change this for
something like a humanoid, right? Like,
where it can actually move around and do
things in a room scale. So, we have to
kind of adapt our algorithms and whole
system to to to to accommodate that. So,
it's actually a very interesting topic
because teleoperation teleoperated
mobile manipulation has been there for a
few years. Uh if you I'm I'm not sure if
you guys seen us uh demo from his paper
called Mobile Aloha, where they kind of
tele the robot to do a variety of things
and train a behavioral policy on top of
that, which is actually quite
impressive. Uh but at the same time,
mobile
demonstration are really really hard
luck cuz you have actually have to move
the robots around and uh it's also not
very intuitive to do mobile uh tele
robot demonstrations.
But human data, on the other hand, do
does contain all of the information we
need to actually uh to to kind of learn
from uh
learn to behave in a mobile way. And
specifically, if you look at uh the
product Aria glasses, we could actually
extract a lot of information from just
one one task demonstration. For example,
we can have the hands, actions, or slam
map, and where the person is uh sort of
in in at any given time. So, we can
reasonably expect to recover some sort
of uh mobile manipulation policy from
this data. All right. So, uh with that
in mind, uh
our student uh developed the algorithm
called Emma, uh which kind of is very
similar to Ego Mimic, but it's just
co-trained from human-robot data. And we
actually had to do a lot of full-stack
design to impose the robots and
algorithms so that we can mitigate the
difference between uh the more kind of
the the bigger gaps between human-robots
when you start doing mobile
manipulation.
So, I won't go into too much details uh
of these algorithms. If you're
interested, you can search up the paper.
Uh but at the end of the day, we were
able to train a policy that does these
kind of mobile manipulation tasks uh
with uh through end-to-end learning. And
we were also able to do these kind of
long-range tasks, uh like grocery
shopping, not just like bagging
groceries. Um
Uh
with with just a end-to-end learning
pipeline.
Uh you can see that the kind of the
everything is driven by egocentric
basically. Yeah.
And we were able to see a kind of a
drastic kind of boost in performance
compared to just calibration data. So
given the same amount of time, if you
combine
like six space
manipulation teleoperation policy plus
mobile human data, it vastly outperforms
the mobile teleoperated demonstration
data. And we see a very very clean
scaling curve as you add more human data
into the system, the policy performance
increases.
And after that, we started working on a
few other things around this. And one of
the most recent kind of ongoing work is
to really deploy some of the things to a
full-blown humanoids with dexterous
hands and everything. So this is really
our early kind of experiments on testing
the replay of human
from human data to robots. Yeah.
Okay. So I want to kind of end this
talk. Uh
How much time do I have?
Uh you still have you still have
time. All good.
I can't hear you. Sorry. You still have
time.
Okay. Good. All right. Awesome. So
Yeah. So
I kind of want to
reflect on what we built. Like there are
many other works that happened in our
lab that build around the kind of this
triangle like better hardware, better
algorithms, better human experience.
So we like the in this talk we talked
about like Eagle mimic which kind of
first time that that established this
triangle for human data. We improved the
algorithm and we improved the
the the the sort of the hardware and we
also improved the the whole whole stack
system.
But there are many many other open
questions out there to in order to
better leverage human data for robot
learning.
I would kind of summarize these into
three categories. One is hardware
systems, the other is all the data
algorithms, and third is the whole
research community.
Um specifically, we're interested in how
to better capture human experience
context, how to design better hardwares
for robots so that they're more
human-like, what roles for human robot
each play in a learning algorithm, and
how to drive the collective progress for
learning from human data for robot
learning.
Um so, the claim here is that we've
already kind of captured certain aspect
of human data human experience through
these kind of wearable devices.
Uh but, if you look at if you think more
about this, first-person videos are not
sensorimotor experience, and they're not
decision-making context. So, there are a
few kind of layers gap between
first-person video all the way to things
that are kind of
decision-complete, so to say, for robot
learning.
Um first of all, sensorimotor experience
our sensorimotor experience is
multimodal. It's not just first-person
video, right? So, we we capture the
videos effectively, but on the tactile
side is for example,
uh there we're nowhere near capturing
the complete like force and tactile
signals that we use daily to kind of do
this kind of fine-grained contact rich
manipulation yet.
And on the other side
and the context necessary for
decision-making is also more than just
instantaneous observation, right? It's
not just mapping my current observation
to that action.
If you look at this first-person video
again, the reason that this chef turned
to the other counter to get the
ingredient or to adjust the heat
occasionally is not to only based on
this instantaneous observation, but
rather what he remembered from a few
minutes ago that he had prepared these
ingredients, and he had years of
training on how to cook certain
ingredients.
We're still far from assimilating this
kind of knowledge to our robots through
end-to-end learning.
And not just we're not also not just
care about like kind of robot
kinematics. Can we Can we kind of make
Sorry. So, the other side of things is
that can we make robot hardware systems
more human-like? For example, we
designed this kind of very simple robots
to show that if you have agile lean
robots, you can learn from human more
effectively. But what if you make human
robots even more human? And in our work,
recent work from Nvidia, we actually
built this kind of a
even more human-like upper body with 22
degree hands and better arms. We're able
to do these kind of tasks
that we were not able to do with with
the tasks with the systems we had
before. So, the question then is that if
we make human robots more human-like,
can we actually learn more effectively
from from human data?
Um and on the second
on the data side,
kind of what we claim is that human
embodiment is universal and has scalable
data source. More human-like robots will
make human data more useful for robot
learning. So, if you kind of think about
this in your head, what we're claiming
really is that we have a lot of human
data and we have some embodiment
specific data to ground this this
this this this this prior knowledge. So,
the question is what roles should human
and robot data each play in this in this
whole setting?
Um and
most of you Some of you probably have
seen kind of this analogy of like our
data being kind of a pyramid where you
have more scalable data sources on the
basement Sorry, on the foundation also
the less more scarce or more kind of
high-quality data on the top. So, for a
human robot data, our pyramid will look
like this.
But where we kind of fine-tune or
pre-train human data with robot data.
But I argue that just like how we we can
actually flip this pyramid and say maybe
more robot data or high-quality robot
data or better policy can actually
enable us to learn better learn from
this human data. So we may be able to
kind of flip this pyramid and say
it's only if we have more kind of better
robot foundation model can we better
learn from human data. So, you know,
recent collaboration with
collaboration with PI physical
intelligence will kind of validate this
hypothesis by saying that maybe a
stronger foundation policy model can
enable better human robot transfer. We
saw that indeed if you actually
pre-train your robot foundation model
better like with more cross-modality
robot data, we actually can see a bigger
jump when you fine-tune it with robot
with human data. So,
and we also saw this sort of in this
kind of Disney
embedding map where
with more with better
VLA model foundation models,
when you add in the human data, they
actually
align better with the with the
in-distribution robot data. So, if you
recall the Eagle Bridge picture,
now we're saying that if you have VLA
better VLAs, you achieve a similar
effect with human robot alignment.
And finally,
the question is can we drive collective
progress? So, I recognize learning from
human data is still kind of a
I wouldn't say a niche field, but it's
actually resource-intensive field.
We we've seen a lot of kind of
collective efforts on collecting a lot
of robot data together. For example,
Oyer I think was also part of some of
these efforts.
The question then becomes can we
actually
kind of drive this progress of the whole
risk community by building some shared
infrastructure from let's say data sets
to policy learning algorithms to
evaluation pipelines to the to to kind
of to close the whole loop. And
the hope is that if we kind of
kind of open source all these data sets
and infrastructure, we are able to do
better drive the performance
and drive the kind of collective
progress of the community. And
I kind of just give you a very sneak
peek of what we're going to release in a
few weeks. It's called EgoVerse. It's
exactly that. So we're able to kind of
put together resources from
many different institutions and also
companies to build these data sets and
all the infrastructures to deploy this
these human-to-robot transfer algorithms
on a variety of different embodiments.
We're just going to show this is roughly
what a data set looks like. It's roughly
1,300 hours of human data,
but it's still increasing. So every day
we we have companies kind of contribute
their data some part of their data into
internal policy among our academic
partners.
And we also have these kind of
interfaces to browse through these data
on a web portal. And we also across
three different universities, we we
cross-validated this data be useful for
for for robot learning. So for example,
we were able to show like the exact same
policy learning
pipeline
deployed on three completely different
robots and achieve similar performance
jump. Uh
uh the by learning from human data.
Okay, I think I'm slightly over time. So
here are the three main papers discussed
during this talk and here are the
funding agencies. And if you're
interested in learning more about the
type of work we do, you're welcome to
visit our web lab website or just email
me if you have questions. And thank you.
>> Cool. Thanks a lot for
uh thanks a lot for the amazing talk. Um
does anybody have any questions for
Dunfei?
Thank you very much.
Hello. Thank you for a nice
presentation.
I have a question about the quality of
the data that you can get by human
egocentric. You've talked in the
beginning of the class.
>> it's a it's a bit muff. Can you maybe
hold your mic closer to you or
a bit hard to hear.
>> [laughter]
>> Um can you hear me better now?
Yeah, yeah, better, yeah.
Okay. So, the question I have is about
Yeah, sorry. Go ahead.
It's about the quality of the data that
you can get uh using egocentric human
data.
Yeah.
>> Because when you teleoperate, you get
like high-quality data, I imagine. And
like when you operate using hum- like
humans, you don't get the exact same
type. And I wanted to know what the
bridge is and
like how you're able to improve
teleoperation data through humans.
Yeah, I think that's a very like it's
it's a
very fundamental question is that what
do we learn from human data? Um so, I
have like I have a very very long answer
to this question, but let me just
summarize my thoughts.
Is that um
right now, today, well, how we're using
these human data is really just kind of
adding that into a training mix
uh and just use our intuition to bridge
as many kind of
gaps that we we see as possible. For
example, humans move a lot faster in
robot teleoperation. So, we need kind of
align their align their speed together
so so they can learn shared
representation.
They will move our head a lot, so maybe
we will tell our demonstrator not move
our head a lot so that I have a stable
view.
But so so that we're we're kind of
treating this as a distributional
alignment problem so that we can
make humans more data more robot data
like. But in the future, I think
distributed around, we should actually
make our robot more be able to generate
more human-like behaviors such that I
can better leverage human data. So
So I don't think that directly answers
your question, but at least that that's
kind of the
for the time being
where we have hacks. For in the
long-term future, I think the future is
bright in the sense that once we have
better have better hardware, we can more
systematically solve this problem.
Well, thanks. We have more one more
question here.
Hi.
How do you estimate forces from the
video?
We don't.
Right now, we don't. We actually have
There's a one paper that I did not talk
about it's called mimic touch that we
start to use tactile, not force. Very
importantly, not force.
But with fingers.
Sorry. Okay.
Is that the problem?
It must be scary to deploy a robot
without knowing
forces.
Yeah, force is force is hard to measure,
right? Cuz force, if you think about it,
is is not really about your fingertip
force, but the overall force you exert
to the object. So
So it's a kind of force transmission
problem that like can you actually
estimate how much overall force you
exert on a given object
in addition to your fingertip like
sensing of tactile. So
that's an incredibly hard problem that
we will able to solve will have to
solve, but now we don't actually have
the hardware to be able to measure force
or tactile uh, uh, in a high high enough
of fidelity.
Um, I have a question on top of that
question. What do you think about event
cameras to estimate force
on tactile force?
Event camera. So, event cameras are
useful when you have a rapid drastic
change of speed on different things, uh,
but if you are talking about tactile
force, I think they're mostly invisible
from egocentric view. Uh, so if you
think about like when you're holding
something, uh, your your actually your
your the contact you don't directly
like see the contact between fingertip
and object because by definition it's
occluded, right? So,
uh, unless you put an event camera
inside your fingertip like GelSight.
That might be actually be something to
look into. Uh,
but again, I I think we don't have the
right hardware for measuring force or
tactile yet. At least like if you want
to bridge the human-robot gap.
Hello. Um, another question. Uh, thanks
for the talk. Um, I imagine across these
results like, um, every time you had a
task it was a, um,
model that was trained specifically for
that task. Um, and you showed some of
that distribution alignment type stuff
with Um, but kind of just interested in
your thoughts on like continual
learning. So, Mhm.
>> would this egocentric human data show
like better performance in this like
continual learning setting than kind of
teleop? And what are your kind of
predictions on that? Yeah. That's an
excellent question. I I think this is
more of like, uh, so my view about
continual learning is that human data is
more suitable for studying this problem
because you can imagine a setting where
you want to adapt your home robots to a
new home just by observing how humans
like interact with their environment in
their homes. Uh,
than sort of having the human collect
robot on robot teleop data to adapt the
robot to that new home. So,
I don't I I have a particular good idea
about how to solve this problem from the
sort of algorithm sense, but I think
it's a more it's a very kind of suitable
problem to just be studied in the
human-to-robot transfer setting.
Cool. Thank you very much. Let's thank
Danfei again for the amazing talk.
>> [applause]